Grecia crece por encima de la media
europea pero en mercados como este de
Atenas los ciudadanos sufren la alta
inflación de los alimentos básicos el
país además ofrece pocas oportunidades a
jóvenes como erini baleaca Generalmente
soy una persona optimista y feliz pero
cuando miro el panorama general me
siento perdida
para las elecciones del domingo 21 de
mayo erini no tiene mucha esperanza como
casi medio millón de jóvenes en los
últimos años a veces piensan migrar
creo que Grecia te mantiene en un estado
de estancamiento por las malas o pocas
oportunidades que te da y que te quita
la motivación para avanzar por
testimonios como este esperanza es una
de las palabras que el ex Primer
Ministro de izquierdas
gusta usar en su campaña lo vemos allá
donde vamos por toda Grecia la esperanza
se ha convertido en la nueva decisión
porque la gente no puede soportar cuatro
años más de arrogancia y de indiferencia
cifras sueña con Volver al poder tras
gobernar entre 15 y 2019 sin embargo las
últimas encuestas le auguran un 26,9% de
los votos casi siete puntos menos que a
mitsuakis quien recibiría un 33,6% de
los sufragios la subida de las
inversiones y las políticas sociales
durante la pandemia parecen superar a la
mala imagen tras el accidente de tren
que el pasado 28 de febrero dejó 57
muertos y llevó al adelanto electoral y
a los escándalos por escuchas y legales
a opositores Espero que mis próximos
cuatro años sean años de crecimiento
rápido que también limite desigualdades
el domingo serán elegidos 280 diputados
por voto directo otros 20 Irán al
partido más votado